هذه موتا في سالي النسخة السعودية
من البتراء والأردن منذ آلاف
السنين كانت على طريق تجاري مهم يوجد
أكثر من 130 مقبرة هنا
بعضها محفور بشكل كبير في
الوجوه الصخرية الآن ومن المقرر
تحويلها إلى متحف خارجي ضخم
بمساعدة
علماء الآثار الفرنسيين ، من الصعب
تصديق ذلك ، لكنهم كانوا واحة
حيث زرعوا الكثير من الحبوب
وأشجار النخيل وأشجار الزيتون وحتى
القطن وهو نبات يتطلب
الكثير من المياه لذلك هناك 132 بئراً
التي وجدناها
وسجلناها وقدمت هذه الآبار شكلين من
المياه يكفيان لزراعة كل هذه المحاصيل ، كل ذلك
جزء من خطة التحول في المملكة العربية السعودية
المعروفة باسم رؤية السعودية 2030 خلال
العقد المقبل ، يريد أكبر اقتصاد في الشرق الأوسط
مضاعفة عدد
السياح إلى 30  مليون شخص
لديهم
مشاريع طموحة بمليارات الدولارات
لمساعدتهم على القيام بذلك ، حيث
تأخذ مدينة الملك عبد الله
الاقتصادية الجديدة هذه على بعد 100 كيلومتر شمال
جدة.  هي بالفعل وجهة رئيسية
للسياح المحليين مع
ملعب غولف دولي
سيستضيف الجولة الأوروبية العام المقبل
ومع مناظر خلابة على طول البحر الأحمر
لدى مؤيديها طموحات عالمية ،
فإن الزخم لجعل هذه الوجهة السياحية
يحدث بشكل واضح والآن
نحن '  إعادة الانتقال إلى المستوى التالي حقًا ،
نعود مرة أخرى إلى ملعب الجولف
ونحن الآن في نقاش حول استضافة
الأحداث الدولية ، ولدينا أيضًا
منشآت رياضية أخرى قيد
التطوير بالإضافة إلى أننا أيضًا
نناقش الأحداث الدولية ، لذلك
هذا هو  تتحرك بسرعة كبيرة لي
وبسرعة كبيرة في اتجاه أن تصبح
وجهة سياحية تعرفها عليها على
أساس عالمي تشمل المشاريع الكبرى
الأخرى مدينة النيون
المستقبلية وتطوير منتجعات فاخرة في 50
جزيرة على البحر الأحمر ستكون إحداها
بناها ريتشارد
برانسون شبكات السكك الحديدية عالية السرعة التي تعبر
البلاد وتطوير المطارات
تحت
كل شيء بهدف الانعطاف  في
مكان معروف بصعوبة زيارته
إلى النقطة السياحية المحتملة التالية
في هذه المنطقة
John dev Tereus Dubai